une ligne droite pour aller droit au but
neuf procureurs démocrates bien haut
rang pour en découdre
les avocats de donald trump
suivent derrière un procès historique
pour une introduction tout aussi
marquantes
bon
sénateurs le président a été mis en
accusation par la chambre des
représentants des états unis le 13
janvier dernier pour avoir fait cela
vous vous demandez ce qu'est un crime et
un délit élevé selon notre constitution
c'est un crime et un délit grave si ce
n'est pas un délit impénitent alors il
n'y a rien de tel
les démocrates ont choisi de rappeler à
la chambre haute du parlement
l'effet du 6 janvier 2021 lorsque les
supporters de donald trump avait envahi
le capitole le clan démocrate affichant
également un tweet du 45e président des
états unis
deux heures après l'attaqué ce dernier
appelé les manifestants à rentrer chez
eux tout en les saluant chaleureusement
8 à maui date oui chaque fois que je lis
ce tweet ça me fait froid dans le dos le
président des états unis s'est rangé du
côté des insurgés
il a salué leur cause il a validé leurs
attaques
il leur a dit souvenez-vous de ce jour
pour toujours les présidents ne peuvent
pas déclencher une insurrection dans
leurs dernières semaines et s'en allait
ensuite comme si rien ne s'était passé
une première journée marquée par une
question peut-on juger ou non un
désormais ex-président un simple citoyen
selon les mots des avocats de donald
trump ce procès déchirera ce pays d'une
façon que nous n'avons vu qu'une seule
fois précédemment dans notre histoire
en réalité nous sommes ici car la
majorité à la chambre des représentants
ne veut pas affronter donald trump comme
rival politique à l'avenir c'est la
vraie raison pour laquelle nous sommes
ici
si donald trump été reconnu coupable le
milliardaire républicain ne pourrait
plus briguer la maison blanche dans
quatre ans d'ailleurs son actuel
locataire joe biden n'entend pas
commenter les différents échanges de ce
procès beaucoup de familles sont en
insécurité alimentaire elles sont en
difficulté c'est ça mon travail le sénat
à son travail il est sur le point de le
commencer et je suis sûr qu'ils vont
bien se conduire et c'est tout ce que
j'ai à dire sur la destitution
cette fameuse question de
constitutionnalité finalement tranché à
la fin de cette première journée
les cinquante sénateurs démocrates et
six sénateurs républicains ont estimé
que le procès pouvait bien se poursuivre
et du ray mercredi place à l'exposé des
faits chaque camp dispose d'un maximum
de 16 heures pour convaincre